hallo everybody and welcome to another
one our flippin challenge today I have
managed to scrape together 100 mil
without selling off too much stuff I
just want to see what the possibilities
are with 100 mil and it's a nice even
starting amount and one thing I would
like to focus on there's some more
expensive high-volume item so we're
gonna have a look at that first yeah
let's go ahead and get started ok start
off here the wrench and champa looks
like as a pretty good let me read you
that red chin Champa before anyone kills
me it looks like it has a pretty good
margin on it we'll go ahead and we'll do
10,000 why not I will go ahead and
reduce it by a bit people ask me pretty
consistently why I do that and just so I
don't hit the buying limit cuz if I hit
a 10k which often is the buying limit I
wouldn't be able to check it again after
okay a 16 GPA margin on green dragon
leather is not too bad either I will go
ahead and do 10k these guys why not
that's a little pricey but I mean we got
the money for it
we got 591 of these you are ready yeah
but we'll see if that continues on or
not next up we're gonna do a couple
higher volume or rare items and probably
do a barrows flip let's try the rims
robe skirt we're just gonna go in price
check it acts that just will be better
we can do ten of them anyway so 1092
into 10:47 that's pretty good we'll go
ahead and put an offer in for those guys
and that we're gonna do nine so that's a
nice just 10 mil invested there not too
bad as presently none of these have come
through yet another one we're gonna do
is krills leather top same deal with the
other run nice and cheap for the margins
that gives usually 1669 and are gonna
sell it for
sixteen three seven it's only 30k but
that's not too bad at all
hopefully it'll be a nice quick flip too
so we'll do nine of those as well
okay so Ashley's bought three of rims
robe skirts all at once and that we're
looking to sell those offer ten and nine
to hopefully pop those in there nice
easy quick flip and really decent margin
for what it is and the rest of things
are slowly coming through then we have
40 mil ileft so we do need at least two
offers lots and probably one more to
sell these guys off so we'll probably
invest in something reasonably expensive
and the Kirill's leather top or tossing
in for 1669 so just a 30k profit I'm not
terrible okay then we're gonna do an
amulet of torture why not
I very quick item to flip eleven point
four mil and we're gonna sell it for
eleven three four - that's kind of what
I was hoping for not something too crazy
of a margin max meand you three these
guys at a time and it'll cap out at five
maybe let's have a look oh it looks like
eight for the tortures that's reasonable
okay we had a torture come through
already for 11 342 and Marcella off for
11400 okay we sold off both the leather
tops already a nice quick profit there
and we have another arm slot freed up
okay we have two more three more leather
skirts coming through and all the
tortures are done as for sell them is
for sixteen six eight pop those in there
I think we're getting 30k in each one of
these that's well 90k not too bad and
the tortures are through hopefully can
actually sell those off first before we
find more eleven that three nine seven
is where we're hoping to sell them for
but they should be trading more than
that so let's try eleven three nine five
and that would be 34 28 five and we
bought them all for 34 one or zero to
six would be 150 k on the torturers
right now which would be happy with and
the diamond bolt e's are looking pretty
promising a 7gp margin on that is pretty
good I was looking to go for a little
more expensive high-volume items but
that will do
and that will do 10,000 of these guys as
well um I've gotta change my mind here I
think I should begin selling these red
chin chocolates because the margin on
them was actually extremely good plus
I'm pretty sure the limit for this is
actually 7k and not 10 1,800 now see
good still okay we got a first robe
skirt sale which is nice we still
managed to get a 32k margin which is
okay but I mean that'll be a hundred and
fifty K and all that once it's sold and
it's more important to just get these
sales coming too quickly and there we go
and another one came through right then
okay all three of the leather tops have
sold off and we have another three to
sell off as well which we're gonna be
able to put him in for sixteen six eight
sixteen six eight K and those will sell
off pretty quickly it seems and now the
bridge and chomp buzz we've hit the buy
limit for us we can pull that out and
toss him in the cell for I guess 1,800 I
can't actually check it out
unfortunately okay we have two sales for
the torture amulets we had to produce it
quite a bit but I'm still happy with
that margin again quick easy done and
that's kind of what I was hoping to do
with this one our online of these have
come through as well as we'll have to
pop that one in there as well for 1668
oh right I always [__] this up it's
actually 15 for the Bears item so I can
actually do more of these guys and why
not cuz they've been so good we have a
by offering here somewhere
yes we do and we'll go do another five
of these because they've just been
flipping very quickly and we're still
getting these 30k margin um yeah there's
another one right away coming through
and ever going to pull out the torture
kits is worth doing more of these maybe
34 116 we bond 434 0 to 6 yeah why not
and we'll do
another three yeah that sounds good and
all of the rope security coming through
and well we'll go put another five in
because these are selling off reasonably
quickly and we have the offer here yes
we do and we're gonna do another five of
these guys okay the green drinking
leather is completely terrible it's only
as a 3gp margin on it and it's not
coming through its person have been and
this while we have a chance still 1785
[__] in 1784 what a waste of time get
rid of that all right that's all gone
only took a few seconds and we get the
money back there more importantly and
offer slot another quick easy one that
is easy to do is the band of God sword
go ahead and roll just go price check
that one so quick twenty eight five six
and we're selling it for twenty eight
three three yeah okay I mean that's 23 K
sure why not
and it went through seven of the band of
swords not great margin but we'll do it
anyway we already wasted the money price
checking it okay be sold off the for
leather skirts we had 30 K on each one
of those times 4 is 120 key right there
nice and easy and I guess we have four
more to sell there we go and we're
selling them for sixteen six eight nice
easy money there 16 six eight and that
we had a to torture amulets coming
through if I already sold them off we're
not getting great merchants on them but
again quick and easy okay so we sold off
the to torture amulet kits that's gonna
be another five we've sold in total in
six totally in total I know has a limit
of eight on it so I guess good buy
another one why not and we'll just do
one and we're selling this one off for
same price eleven and three seven two
nice quick flip again
eleven three seven two and we have five
of the curls tops coming through and
none of them sold yet but we have 37
minutes left such okay in the last
torture came through another one already
sold that's it's a very quick process
here eleven the 372 and there we go that
is everything flipped for the tortures
we need to find another item now
okay Drock Somerset's have a 12 K margin
not great but they are so quick as it
will go and do it anyway we'll just do a
them so we have a little bit of money
left over finally sold off some of these
chin Champa which is nice because that's
been a very lengthy process and then the
ugly rope skirts are coming through so
we're gonna probably drop that back down
to what we had them at before which was
ten seventy nine okay the Circa ring has
a 37k margin on it which is actually
quite nice for the item I had to get
seven for this guy as well toss in some
of those and the chin chompers are all
sold off can't remember off the top of
my head but ended up buying those four
but we got a pretty decent margin on the
chin jobless I wouldn't be surprised
we've got 150 200 K on that ok the rocks
plate skirt has a 35 K margin on it not
bad I will just do 14 and why not let's
just go hard or go home I guess
and the Bears items have been treating
us very nicely Berserker rings are
coming through pretty quickly and we're
gonna try to continue to hit that 30 K
margin 26 6 7 will some form and all of
the curls leather tops have sold pretty
sure we got it with a 30k margin on that
and be sold 15 of them i bringing
probably 450 KF that I guess which is
very nice the band who's got swords I'm
gonna lower down a little bit because
they should be Sun wake working that and
we'll put him down to 28 1 sure what
sells off not a great margin on this
anyway ok buddy
50k margin on the toxic Trident which is
nice person gonna claim and he sell
offers we have that might help there we
go and yeah 50
roughly which is very nice gonna go and
do quite a few of these guys pretty sure
the limit is
let's try 7 and all the Berserker rings
are through all seven of them and none
of them I've sold yet so probably not
continuing to get that margin but I will
try 26 ok we sold off all of the band of
God swords
28:41 I need the instant replay on this
[__] thing yeah I think we got like
15k max on that okay we actually
instantly sold off all the Deva rocks
plate skirts for a 34k margin which is
150 K it right there nice and simple
we've got another two of those is that
off perfect okay literally insta sold
these guys for eleven that three nine
whoops well still happy with that
alright so we bought these a long time
ago and we'll rough relatively long time
ago we'll see we can still get the same
margin of well it's only 12 K but it's
something and we finally are selling off
these stupid rings we're down to an 8k
margin on these guys so [__] the rare e
35 K margin on eternal boots why the
[__] not
let's do it and we're just gonna do
seven of these right off the bat and
well I'm just hitting buttons on even
though I'm doing okay seven good tossa
in there the tridents we're actually
still getting a 50k march now we just
sold one for a 50k profit perfect and so
I guess we just broke even at that point
but and so I went off for the same 27/5
okay all the azúcar ring sold off we
probably got 7k and these things not too
great but at least we've got the offer
slot back all the armor set sold off as
well
yeah don't remember yeah no we'll have
to figure that out later
oh wait note there right there three
zero an eight one eighteen point four
eight eight move look for 18 five five
eight that's still a more profit it all
adds up okay battle staves have a forty
five GP margin on them we're gonna go to
you quite a bit we'll do five K which
would lead to a very nice profit from
that okay all of the rims rope skirts
sold off finally we managed to get
pretty much a 30k margin each one of
those it's a really nice from that we
just sold off a toxic trident for
another 58 profit this one's very
consistently buying one selling one and
buying another one happen pretty happy
with it because that's a very nice
profit on each one look it up a four
hundred K if you flipped the entire
buying limit not sure we're gonna make
it wait that's not right
okay I think on the pull out the plate
skirt and only have 16 minutes left and
haven't sold one in quite some time now
I've got another one coming through I
really don't wanna really use this
anymore yeah let's pull this out eleven
to seven let's try selling for okay we
got another to toxic Triton's coming
through and we might have to pull that
out even though there's only one left
we'll put item Liam fifteen minutes
remaining and so on for twenty eight
seven three that's another 150 K if we
sell these off okay honestly we have 15
minutes left and we have quite a few
items left so I think we're probably
gonna focus on selling and hope that
actually will sell in time because
otherwise I think we'll be losing a bit
of money on some of these flips okay we
sold off all the eternal boots we had to
reduce it quite a bit for those to sell
off but okay the last Fox plate skirt
sold off 27k in each of those is about
140 km profit pretty happy with that and
these stupid metal stabs
won't sell as we've dropped them down to
86 pretty much what we bought them for
these ten ever really good margin on
them but they buy like ten times quicker
and then they sell okay we kind of got
fed up with the battle slabs and drop
them down
and they sold off pretty much right away
perfect and that we sold them for eighty
six hundred and that is pretty much what
we bought them for I'm almost certain so
let's go ahead and take our last offer
there and see how much money we made in
one hour from 100 mil now it looks like
we made at least one mil I kind of found
to be a little more but let's go ahead
and price check it here 1.7 million but
I kind of thought that I would be
getting a bit more than that but to be
honest my merchants weren't great at 30
40 K it was kind of I was going off of
just high-volume
boat flips of kind of expensive rares or
high-volume rares I should say but
anyway pretty solid our still and 1.7
million our is you know it's still
pretty decent and honestly if you were
not restricted to this hourly setting
you probably do better by being a bit
more patient and getting better
merchants anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
if you did don't forget to toss a like
on the video
I always hops out and I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
you